hello gigachads and welcome back to the
channel sorry I missed a video this past
week on Thursday I was starting to make
it on like Tuesday and then I thought I
came up with a distributed consensus
algorithm and I spent like
two hours trying to figure out if I
actually did and it's still kind of
unclear to me whether I did so I'm
either going to be a billionaire or I
wasted two hours either way the EV is
pretty good but uh yeah without a doubt
now I actually have to make a YouTube
video so let's go ahead and get into it
for today all right so the topic of
today's video is going to be a
linearizable storage so what is
linearizable storage why do we need it
how is it relevant for the subject
matter that we've covered so far well
basically we need it for let's say
correct reads so imagine that I'm
building a distributed lock meaning that
we have one node that uh you know kind
of holds the lock on it but a bunch of
different clients need to be able to
grab it and if that node goes down we
need to make sure that basically the
person who is holding the lock is still
holding that lock right we need to be
distributed and tolerant in the face of
faults so that is going to be you know
let's say just one person can hold that
lock and that invariant needs to stay
true additionally for something like a
database leader it needs to be the case
that there's only one database leader
and if for some reason that leader were
to go down that we don't switch in a way
that is going to kind of contradict what
everyone in the system believes and
understands that leader can't come back
up and then be a second leader all of a
sudden so linearizable storage for me to
kind of summarize it is this kind of
black box here of a database system
where it is both fault tolerant and all
of the rights are ordered so what does
it allow us to do if all of the rights
are ordered well it basically means that
if we know the order of the rights we
can make sure that our reads never go
back in time right if right one is
saying uh you know like node a is leader
and then you know all of a sudden I read
write two saying node B is leader
there should be absolutely no
possibility that I later then read that
node a is leader or else our storage is
not linearizable I kind of just went
back in time in my system and now our
entire constraints and invariance
forcing everything to be correct have
been completely messed up so how do we
actually order our rights let's look at
a few examples that we've spoken about
uh so let's start with single leader
replication for example the way that we
order our rights within our nodes is a
replication log the replication log
basically says you know we've got to
write one and a right two and a right
three and you send that replication log
from the leader
to the followers and by doing so we know
that the leader and the followers so all
of the nodes in our cluster agree on the
order of all the rights what about
multi-leader and leaderless replication
well obviously this is going to be a
little bit more challenging simply
because of the fact that now our rights
can go to a bunch of different places
and we can have concurrent rights so how
can we establish an order across them we
can't really establish a correct order
right it's not really possible to say
like hey I know for a fact that the
right on one node came before another
node but we can establish an order that
is consistent among the nodes right so
we can get all the nodes to agree on The
Ordering of the rights and how can we do
that well we could use something like
version vectors or a lan Port clock so
just as a reminder to everyone a version
Vector is what we have shown over here
where as you can see we've got say like
the version Vector on the left says
three comma one and the version Vector
on the right says two comma two so on
the right database node you've seen two
updates from the left database node and
two updates from the right database node
and on the left database node we've seen
three updates from the left database
node and one update from the right
database node now it's important to note
that because three comma 1 and 2 comma
two are kind of interleaved right like
three is greater than two but one is
less than two that these two version
vectors are concurrent and so
technically there's no complete order
right we can assign a complete order
where we would say like okay in a
tiebreaker choose the version Vector
where you know the left kind of index is
greater right so we could say in tie
Breakers we arbitrarily choose an
ordering and that's effectively what we
do with lanport clocks as well the one
big difference with Lamport clocks is
that version vectors take o of n space
where n is the number of replicas so if
I added a third guy over here now all of
a sudden our version vectors need three
elements Lamport clocks always
exclusively take two elements and so as
a result they're a bit more compact to
determine the ordering in multi-leader
and leader list replication so let's
quickly learn how those work so this is
going to be a little bit of a
complicated slide but let's go ahead and
talk about it so I mentioned that
lampord clocks take constant space of
one so how do they work let's imagine
imagine we have one client over here on
the left side of our screen another
client on the right side of our screen
and the point is they're going to be
making concurrent rights and we want to
be able to order them so let's call this
database B we'll call this database a
and so the point here is that every
single kind of element of our system uh
both the client the databases and the
other client all have a local counter
and so as you can see that's all going
to start at zero I have them lined up
right here b0 and the point is every
single time that you make a right you're
going to increment your counter both on
the client and the database however the
kicker is that you don't just increment
your counter by one oftentimes you do
but you actually take the max of the
counter that's currently on the client
and the database that the right is going
to and you add one to that so just to
show things off since clients are both
starting let's start over here since
both clients are starting with a counter
of zero and both databases are starting
with a counter of zero when you perform
the right you perform a right and
everyone increments their counter to one
because you're going to say well this
guy was at zero this guy was at zero
they're writing to one another so
increment both the client and the
database counter to one do the same
thing on the top now what's going to
happen is that client 2 is going to
write to database B again so as you can
see this right is now going to be B
comma 2 because the right is going to
database B and the counter on the client
is two now what's going to happen is
that this client is going to write again
over here but this time to node a and so
you can see that the counter is going to
be a comma 3. so why is it a comma 3
instead of a comma 2 because keep in
mind that the counter on node a was
still only one the reason it's three is
because the counter on client 2 was
already two so what we do is we take the
max of the two possible counters we add
one to it and that is our new Lamport
clock number see we have a comma 3 and
then the same thing over here
when client 0 or client 1 rather is
going to write to node a we're going to
take the max of the two counters so
recall that a already at a counter of 3
at this point from the last right and
client one had only a counter of one
from over here and we're going to add
one to it and now we have four so this
all seems very arbitrary what am I
getting at here the point is you can
assign a lan port timestamp to every
single right and then once we've
assigned those Lamport time stamps to
every single right we can actually
Express an ordering over our rights that
is total we don't have a concept of
concurrency here because what we can do
to settle ties when things have the same
counter is we can just pick an order of
the notes so let's say the rule is
basically that first we're going to sort
by counter and then if there's a tie
encounter we sort by node so that means
that A1 this guy over here is our first
right then we have B1 this guy over here
then we have B2 which makes sense
because 2 is the next highest counter
rather you know the next lowest count
then we have a comma 3 because 3 is
going to be the next lowest one and then
finally a comma 4 because 4 is the next
lowest number notice that when we have
two things with the same counter value
A1 and B1
that the fact that we use the node tie
breaker there means that A1 comes first
because we will choose a first since
that is our arbitrary node ordering that
we've chosen so this is one way that we
can actually Implement a complete
ordering over all of our rights in a
leaderless or multi-leader replication
setup however it still does not create
linearizable storage the reasoning being
because of the fact that in this setup
while we are able to create an ordering
over our rights the ordering is kind of
after the fact okay so let's go ahead
and go through this example of how
things might not necessarily be
linearizable in a multi-leader
replication setup even if you are using
Lamport clocks to order the rights let's
imagine I have a client and he is going
to be hanging out right here so the
first thing that's going to happen is
we've got a couple of rights that have
gone to each of our databases one is x
equals one to the left database and then
the other is going to be X is equal to 5
on the right database so you can see now
that the x is equal to 5 is technically
the later right because it has this b
equals one Lamport timestamp so this is
the later right
so let's imagine basically that I first
read from this node over here and I get
that X is equal to 1.
then I now go ahead and read from this
node over here and get X is equal to 5.
and then one more time I'm going to read
from my left node and get that X is
equal to 1. even though eventually once
these nodes kind of converge and
replicate their state to each other
where we see X is equal to five and it
gets over here then we'll be in good
shape but until that replication
actually happens we can read these
rights out of order because we know that
X is equal to 5 comes after X is equal
to one because it is the later right so
as long as we have the propensity to be
able to read these rights out of order
our storage is obviously not going to be
linearizable
so let's actually go ahead and talk
about single leader replication because
you might be thinking yourself well
obviously if all the rights go through
one node that's got to be linearizable
right we discussed how there's a
replication log but actually it's not so
how is it not linearizable well let's go
ahead and take a look so let's imagine
the first thing that's going to happen
is we write to our left database over
here let's call this the leader
we're going to write X is equal to 5 to
it and then we're going to write X is
equal to 10 to it so the replication log
looks something like this
x equals five x equals ten and so we're
going to send over X is equal to 5 to
our follower
and then once we basically do that what
we can do is have our client over here
the first thing our client is going to
do is read X is equal to 5 from the
leader the second thing they're going to
do is do another read from the leader
and now you can see oh wait X is
actually equal to 10. however if our
leader goes down during this time and X
is equal to 10
has not yet actually gotten to the
follower
when you read again from the follower
you're going to see that X is equal to
5. because the right has not yet been
propagated so this is not a fault
tolerant linearizable storage solution
even though a single node is itself
linearizable the whole point is this is
distributed systems we need to figure
out a way such that when nodes fail we
can still be sure that our rights are
only being read in that same order
so what we actually need is something
called total order broadcast and what
that means is that everything every
single right that is published to the
system is agreed upon by every single
node not necessarily every node but it's
agreed upon by the storage system in a
way it's such that it exhibits
linearizable reads meaning that your
reads are never going back in time
because again if you're holding a lock
and you're basically just holding that
and then all of a sudden the system
thinks that a previous owner of the lock
is the one holding it you're in huge
trouble so ultimately what does this
come down to we need something called
distributed consensus so that is going
to be the topic of the next video this
was mainly just a primer for it why we
need distributed consensus what it's
useful for but yeah hopefully that makes
things very clear so guys I will see you
in the next one I've got to run to the
gym because I just ate a bunch of donuts
and I'm feeling pretty thick and uh yeah
have a great weekend everyone